>> Role models are undoubtedly important in
the Middle East and perhaps all over the world
but I've been very privilege to listen to
one. King Abdullah- of Jordan; now what makes
him a role model? Well for me he speaks from
here, his heart, he communicates with conscience
and he's clearly a man of vision and these
two ingredients put together takes something
very, very exciting but at the same time appealing
and aspiring qualities this person 00:32 [inaudible].
When he speaks you feel like you know him.
There's no barriers and this is something
that's very exciting. As someone who's studied
theology and someone interested in faith and
studied the Middle East and [inaudible] I've
always been told there's no peace in the Middle
East. Well I think that with communicating
with conscience with a leader like this coupled
with the President Obama who supports this
peace process, I think there really is hope.
My organization [inaudible] his communications
with conscience and I think that we have one
here. [inaudible] to have a role model but
it starts here. No it needs to resonate into
every single home in the Middle East and beyond.